-Our next guest is
an award-winning, best-selling
author and staff writer at
"The New Yorker."
His book, "Rogues: True Stories
of Grifters,
Killers, Rebels and Crooks"
is out today.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Patrick Radden Keefe,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, Patrick!
I'm so happy to have you here.
-It's great to be back.
-So this is a collection of
fantastic stories you've written
over the years
for "The New Yorker"
and grifters, killers,
rebels and crooks --
Did you realize that your work
had this sort of thematic arc
of these kind of people?
-Not at the time.
I mean, the weird thing is,
I take some pride in not having
a beat, and I think of myself
as just kind of
zigging and zagging and
following interesting stories
wherever they go.
And then when I put this book
together,
it's 12 stories
over the course of 12 years.
And I realized I just have like
two or three themes.
I keep coming back, you know,
to these sort of
big personalities who either are
pushing the limits of the law
or living just outside the law.
-You wrote a story about
El Chapo,
and then El Chapo reached out.
-Got in touch. Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's sort of a -- I should
note, wanted to collaborate.
-Yeah, it was a weird -- it was
a very strange scenario.
So occasionally, I'll write
these stories
about people who won't
talk to me.
We call it a writearound, so
it's like, if I'm profiling you
and you won't give me
an interview, I'll just
sort of write around you.
And I did that with El Chapo,
who is in prison in Mexico,
and he couldn't talk.
And so I came out with
this big profile.
And not long after, I got a call
from a guy who introduced
himself as a lawyer
for El Chapo.
And I was just --
I was panicked
because it had not occurred
to me that he would --
He didn't seem like
a "New Yorker" subscriber.
I didn't think he would read --
-Loves the cartoons.
-He only reads the cartoons.
I figured he might have skipped
the article.
And so I was just
kind of dissembling.
I didn't know what to say
to this guy.
And he said,
"We've read the article."
And then he said, "El Senor" --
They call him "El Senor."
He said, "El Senor is ready to
write his memoirs."
And I was -- I had no idea
where this was going.
And so I was just like, "That's
a book I'd like to read."
[ Laughter ]
And he said, "But, sir, is it
a book you would like to write?"
[ Laughter ]
And so I was terrified.
I had to -- Before we got off
the phone, I had said "no"
because it just didn't seem like
a good idea.
I felt like,
even in the best of scenarios,
you know, the ghost writer
and the sub--
sometimes they don't get along,
it doesn't end well.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And what's funny is he called.
So I said "no" on that call.
He called a week later
and he said,
"As you continue to consider
our offer --"
I was, "No, no! I've considered.
I've considered."
But I didn't end up
writing that book.
-You talk about, again,
as a "New Yorker" reporter,
sometimes you got a writearound,
sometimes you're trying to
talk to subjects who are tricky.
They don't like talking to
reporters.
They don't trust them.
Do you have some tricks
in your tool bag?
Have you had luck over the years
sort of developing a technique
to get people to talk
who might otherwise not?
-You know, what I often tell
people is,
"Listen, the train is
leaving the station.
If you don't get on it,
that doesn't mean
it's not going to go.
I'm going to write the piece
whether you cooperate or not."
But the truth is that it's often
the case with some of
these people that, even if you
get the interview,
they're not going to tell you
anything all that helpful.
I had this funny experience with
Gerry Adams,
who was in the Irish Republican
Army, the IRA.
I wrote a book about them
and he wouldn't talk with me.
And I remember just kind of
complaining and saying,
"Oh, God, I wish he would talk."
And another guy who'd been in
the IRA said, "Oh, you know, he
would never tell you anything,
even if he did talk to you."
And I was sort of
insulted by this.
And I said, "Oh, you know, I've
got my -- I've got my ways.
I'm an experienced journalist.
I could probably get
some good stuff
out of Gerry Adams."
And the guy kind of chuckled and
he said, "You know, Gerry's had
what we call
counter-interrogation training,
which means you could be
torturing him
and he wouldn't
tell you anything.
But if you want to go in there
with your wee notebook..."
[ Laughter ]
"...good luck to you."
I'm never living this down.
Any time I'm working at home,
my wife will just kind of roll
her eyes and say,
"Your wee notebook.
Don't forget your wee notebook."
[ Laughter ]
-That's very unfair.
-Yeah.
-You know, you write nonfiction,
but I feel like you write --
and again, you write
about big characters.
You know, you wrote about the
Sacklers in the opioid crisis.
You wrote about the IRA.
It strikes me that one of the
really effective ways you write
is -- obviously,
it's nonfiction,
but it reads like a story.
Is that something
that you set out to do?
Like, to create the characters
in a way
that almost feels like a novel?
-I'm so glad to
hear you say that
if only because I -- I mean,
that's very much by design.
I grew up in a family, like, an
Irish-American family in Boston
where everybody's telling
stories --
[ Man cheers ]
Alright! Boston.
Where people are telling stories
and retelling stories.
And, you know, it's considered
kind of a skill to tell
and retell a story, which I
realize not everybody finds
tremendously amusing.
And so some of it is -- yeah,
it's about, you know, I start
books all the time
that I don't finish.
And so some of it is about
trying to kind of write
these stories in a way that'll
pull you in and hold on to you
and hopefully you'll get
right to the end.
-So you've written
about the IRA.
You've written
about the opioid crisis.
This is "Grifters, Killers,
Rebels and Crooks."
Kids book next, do you think?
[ Laughter ]
-I thought maybe a book on yoga
or meditation.
[ Laughter ]
Or like microdosing thing?
-You and Kesha should write
something.
She's got a real trip of
an experience right now.
-I'm going to approach her
backstage.
-Go ghost hunting with Kesha.
I think you'll enjoy it.
Hey, congratulations
on the book.
It's so great to see you.
Patrick Radden Keefe, everybody.
"Rogues" is available now.
We'll be right back.